he is the co-founder and he's also a
player in the premier lacrosse league
that finished their 2020 season in a
bubble zero positive tests over the
course of their three week tournament
last year and now the upcoming season
for the pll
is set to begin on june 4th at gillette
and all regular season and playoff
matchups will stream on peacock
with some matches also being available
on nbcsn
on on the big and bc
paul rabel is here on the rich eisen
show nice to meet you paul how are you
sir
great rich i don't think i need to spend
much time beyond that honestly that was
great uh it was a great lead-in
no you bet so thanks for coming on paul
appreciate it yeah it's great to meet
you
i'll be on your podcast if you want
we'll chat then no
this has got to be very you got to be
fired up man i mean this is a big deal
for your
league that you have co-founded and
you're playing in this you've got to be
you've got to be psyched yeah we're
pumped this is our third season
um and unbeknownst to probably a lot of
your listeners or or even
a lot of avid or passive sports fans in
the us is
professional lacrosse that existed for
20 years prior to us co-founding the pll
back in 2018 and it was called major
league lacrosse so another thing that we
did this offseason
is is merged with the mll except
different than in aba nba or nfl afl
we took on the future rights of naming
and business operations versus in those
situations
typically the incumbents move forward in
subsequent seasons but
we had a bit of a clash in 2018 we felt
like pro lacrosse could
take a path similar to mls or ufc
over the last 15 years because the new
media like peacock and technology and
we feel like because of participation in
the us and beyond
that we're on that path so a different
model but
we're definitely excited about where
professional lacrosse can go
and again it's you know each team
does have a home city
but you're all playing on the same
weekend in
in a stadium traveling around the
country
and gillette being your first spot and
then
um the home of kenosha state university
uh fifth third bank stadium in atlanta
is your second spot and then
baltimore maryland right there on your
alma mater johns hopkins you're going to
be playing in long
long island and minnesota uh at
minneapolis i mean these are some
considerable fields that you're you're
playing on starting june 4th and
culminating in the middle of september
yeah i mean we didn't
rich we were pretty objective in the way
that we
looked at professional lacrosse it's a
smaller sport there's two million
participants and 10 million fans
and and we weren't going to try to do
what
maybe other leagues had done over the
last 20 years and try to replicate
major league baseball the nba out of the
gates and it's so much lineage and
heritage and
ownership of venues that go into
building a professional sports league
right so we looked at f1 as a model or
tour based models and then we looked at
what works in lacrosse
annually and it's the college final four
where you have four teams the same thing
happens in basketball
they descend in a major market venue and
they play over the course of the weekend
so there's this supply demand curve that
they hit
so where we're at is still our early
stages of building
interest and year-over-year increase in
viewership and sponsorship
through this tour based model and then
we think over the next three to five
years
if we continue to see this growth that
we can flip to a city based and sell
franchises and go in that path so
it's definitely a different twist to
what people are used to consuming for
team sports but in the end you still get
the best players on the field every
weekend right here on peacock the pll
coming to you right here on this uh
outstanding streamer
starting on june 4th paul rabel the
co-founder along with the player
of the premier lacrosse league here on
the rich eisen show you're also
uh a podcaster and season three
of your podcast suiting up with paul
rabel podcast
uh one of your first guests is is a
rarity in this business
of saying yes to any interview um i know
that firsthand
even though he did appear as our first
nfl guest uh in
history of my show on peacock last year
is bill belichick how did that
happen for you paul how'd that come
across yeah well
you know similar i guess to co-founding
a league is
it's rare that maybe athletes cross over
into business or
media and i don't take it lightly
because
you're a seasoned professional at what
you do and there's so much
nuance to interviewing there's so much
nuance to building a company
but i think at the core of what we all
do
is this curiosity so and relationships
and so with bill
he grew up playing lacrosse i met him at
my alma mater
given that he's from maryland and we
built a relationship
and when i got probably about 10 years
into my career i
launched a podcast because i was tipped
off by some friends around the early
stages of it but they were like hey you
keep these interesting relationships
amongst
other athletes and other sports and
other coaches in other sports where
there isn't that traditional any fear or
a barrier that's put up
that you get from the press and i think
it's also at the moment where
conversation is moving into more honesty
and authenticity and you get
less of this a programmable answer
that you would in a typical press
conference you get that in the long form
interview because you can work them in
but with bill it was kind of like hey i
remember
showing up at his office because we had
scheduled this podcast
and we have a lot of trust between us
and um i pop open two mics and i think
he
was expecting maybe me to record it on a
phone
yes and he looked at me and he goes so
is this going to get out to a lot of
people and i said
coach i think it has a chance to get a
few million people
and he was like so we probably should
hold back on the swearing
and i was like yeah we can do whatever
you want we press record in like 30
minutes in he's talking about how
lawrence taylor was the greatest
football
football player he's ever coached and
you know he kind of skipped around maybe
some of the
disciplinary stuff that he was
responsible for
during his time coaching lt but he
shared some really
insightful things about what it takes to
be a great football player
um in his league so if i want belichick
to work blue i tell him it's only going
to be here by about 15 people is that
what i should
is that how i should go about it you get
into his office and you
put up some you know a little bit like a
shady podcast kit
and uh and and maybe uh less of the the
glitz and glamour or all the
professionalism and and you might get a
little bit more out of them
all right good to know good to know the
yes or no questions or something and he
shuts down i know that and
right you know and and uh and so
fantastic and
interestingly enough your first um
weekend in the pll um
is at gillette and uh chris hogan
who a lot of folks know from the nfl is
he he's a teammate of yours he's now
he's left the nfl and he's in the pll
and he's taking up lacrosse now
is that really what he said yeah i mean
chris is a is a unique athlete he's
he's a lacrosse player first i i know
because we've been shooting this docu
on him and he played four years at penn
state he was an honorary metro
all-american
but loved football went out for it
because for what i had talked about
earlier rich
pro lacrosse was really non-existent
even though the property had existed i
mean our average wage and ml
for over a decade was 8 000 bucks for
the season
no health care no distribution and so he
kind of looked at that opportunity and
said how i'm going to try to
play in the nfl um and then he popped
off during that one season of hard
knocks when he was trying out for the
dolphins and they called him 7-eleven
and
again going back to bill bill has an
affinity for lacrosse having played it
and he's brought on a few lacrosse
players will yateman was another one
um and he looks at that creativity we
talked about
uh me coming over and trying out the
patriots at one point i'm glad i didn't
but he's known for kind of
sifting through that talent and
obviously had a great run with chris
winning some super bowls and now chris
has seen the growth of the pll
and i think looked at where his career
trajectory was going in the nfl and said
hey before i just shut down let me try
to get back and
and have an imprint in lacrosse he went
undrafted
in our entry draft um and then got
picked up by the canon team i play on
and
and i'll see him at training camp next
week and uh hopefully he makes a roster
wow so he's trying so he is he like the
tebow of this
uh operation right now i mean he sure
looks like tebow the guy's a freaking
tank
no i'm just saying he's been out he's
been out of the sport for a long time
and you you have a relationship with him
and you're just gonna give him a shot
you know i mean that's basically the way
you
that's you're like the urban minor
that's right anything that you called
out is a
i'm a co-founder and player it's not
gonna last much longer i'm 35 and so
i still think i got it on the field but
there you go everyone thinks i put
burgers
and and uh publish our tweets across the
league and make decisions for coaches
but
it uh there's some things that feel
coincidental and
there's others that the cannons uh
formerly were in boston
as they were a franchise we brought over
from the mol through that merger
and uh the coach as well of the team um
it has you know an affinity for for kind
of new england sports and saul
and had conversations with chris and try
to make a a bet on him but
we'll see what he does i mean i know
he's training his ass off
and uh and he's a player that can play
both ways so he'll probably
come out and and play defensive midfield
which is based like cornerback
and then get the ball and stick go down
to offense and and be a threat on the
offensive there
so he's really the troy brown of the
cannons maybe i mean like the virginia
probably
yeah maybe at dion sanders because he
can
flip around and play all right i like it
um
i guess before i let you go uh i got to
pull on this strand
belichick thought maybe you could try
out like what
receiver is that what you're going to do
what would you wanted to play receiver
i'll send you a clip when we get offline
okay um i i wanted to play receiver
he wanted he wanted me to be a strong
safety i wasn't
fast enough from a verdict from like a
just a straight 40-yard dash as you're
quite familiar with it but i tried to
pitch them you know
rich eisen over the last 15 years has
improved
his 40 time you know like i can improve
my 40 time
and uh and we were going back and forth
i think what he was saying is look
your size and and work ethic and
commitment to sport
um bodes better in that position
um and we went back and forth this was
back when i was 23
and i was captain of team usa at the
time and um
we kind of came to an agreement that it
was the best decision to stay in
lacrosse
yes well it makes sense hey
paul um congrats on on the peacock deal
um appreciate it and uh in advance of
heading off to gillette and your
training camp to get ready for
the pll season that again will be on
regular season and playoff matchup
streaming right here on peacock some
matches available on nbc sn and then the
the final uh the championship week 11 in
washington d.c
will be on nbc congratulations on all
that let's stay in touch
appreciate it rich thanks for having me
you got it that's paul rabel check out
his podcast suiting up with paul rabil
uh and where all podcasts can be
acquired at paul rabel r-a-b-i-l
on twitter and instagram hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here